um
all right i'm gonna wait until a couple
more people get here
but the purpose of my lab today is i'm
gonna be answering questions about um
well i'm just gonna be telling you guys
about like my life changes coming up and
then if you guys have any like questions
about that or any like random stuff i'm
going to update you on that too
but hold on i'm about to pull up
some questions that people
sent me on
okay let's see
yes someone commented this
okay
okay so somebody put in my comment
section
um i never understood why youtubers do
long distance your youtuber you can work
anywhere
okay so i think that comment is i'm
talking about
my relationship and
me moving across the country so i'm
gonna actually go back like a couple
years and explain how i ended up here
um
okay so
a year ago i was working a sales job so
i worked um selling copiers worst job in
the world do not do it
um for a company called konica minolta
and i was living in milwaukee wisconsin
and
i quit my job because i have always had
the lifelong dream of playing overseas
that's like something i've always always
wanted to do
um like literally for for
for years like honestly for years
and i finally saved enough money i was
ready to go um in september of
i want to say that was 2019.
no no 20
okay sorry i'm back i think the internet
that
i've hit 15 for this wi-fi here and it
looks like it's still not even working
um okay so
last year i was working a sales job and
in october of last year
i quit the sales job in order to go play
overseas it's a year-long program um
it's something i've always wanted to do
i was going to go to england
and i was supposed to originally go in
september but then i was postponed till
january and in like october of last year
that was when like the country started
opening up so i really thought in
october like
it's going to be cool i am going to go
play overseas do my lifelong dream and i
figured in that year like i could really
focus on
social thank you hi guys um i someone
said hi in the chat hi jay bones okay so
i was so excited to go like literally i
was gonna go in january um
but then the season actually got
cancelled so
um
yeah so
i actually met
um
sorry i met one yay in november of last
year i was gonna leave in december
got cancelled and moved to september he
like knew this the whole time like i
told him i think around like
like february um that i was still
thinking about going and like he it
wasn't like a secret or anything
um
yeah and like the main purpose of me
going honestly i've just always had the
dream of like living overseas for a year
like living in europe i lived in europe
for three months when i was 18.
and like i just want to go see the world
before i have kids before i
you know have like get married and do
all that stuff like this is just
something i've always wanted to do and
it's funny because in the mana sphere
they'll tell you to just like follow the
guy no matter what um
you know like i think i had a comment
that said
let's see why are you moving you can
afford to take care of you
and
like honestly it's just life experience
and
i have just i love traveling i love
seeing the world and i just i think i'm
never gonna get that experience again
like i'm never gonna have that
opportunity one to play overseas like
that's something i can only do when i'm
young and two to live overseas for a
year so that was like
my thought process in
in going so the program is a year i i'm
going to get a degree
in
psychology um i don't really care that
much about the degree like it's a cool
bonus but i want to do youtube for work
so i don't necessarily like
need it um
um but like it's it's a cool thing to
have
um
so i'm trying to think so then
so yeah and i'll be playing semi-pro i
don't actually know if i'm playing
volleyball or basketball yet because i
actually have the opportunity to play
either or so i'm actually gonna go and
like
try out for both teams and see which one
i think i'd be more likely to play on
um i'm a little bit out of shape i'm a
lot out of shape um
i've been like working out and lifting
so i'm still strong but like
anyone that played college sports knows
that competitive athletics is just like
a different level of in shape like
literally a different level
um
yeah so that's what
oh she's my ubereats here
hold on hold on
oh no not yet okay i think it said it
was supposed to come
yeah i still got like a half hour
um
how can i reach out to you privately
regarding business um
yeah if you'd like a clap or something i
don't know what
you're looking for but you can always
reach out to me
oh god something's loud in the hallway
um reach out to me via instagram so
i
always like check my dms i don't always
respond because i get like a lot of
messages but
yeah message me on instagram if i don't
respond right away you can always
message me again like i don't get
irritated or anything
um but yeah instagram i would say is the
best way or just pearlythings at
gmail.com i prefer instagram it's just
like easier but if you want to be more
professional like we could do email too
okay but yeah so i'm gonna be going to
east london university that's the school
and
um
yeah i don't know i'm trying to think
like what else you would want to know
about that
but yeah i'm like actually really
excited
for
for that i'm trying to think of what
else you want to know about the
experience
um
i'm actually i'm not living on campus
i'm getting my own apartment
oh but this is what i was gonna say so
people were asking me about my like
relationship status so for a while
um i was single um
because like we just broke up like going
on to
like knowing that i was gonna leave um
but
we did decide to give it another shot so
we're gonna
do distance and yeah i don't know
i'm excited i miss them
um okay
my red dress on fresh and fit was
beautiful thank you my naturally redhead
yes i am a redhead i only dyed my hair
once brown and that was like over a year
ago so i think it's pretty much out now
um
what other questions do you guys have
you guys have other questions
see what other questions people have
asked me
i think i'm too casual on this account
to be honest sometimes
um
what which other european spots am i
going to go to so my plan is after
season
um i'm going to literally like travel
the world so i'm go like depending on
how much money i have because it's
going to depend on how much money i make
on youtube feel free to donate if you
want to like contribute you know
um but yeah so
ideally if i have enough money i would
literally love to just like go from
country to country and travel the world
for like
months after i get my degree
um am i thinking about doing only fans
uh no not at all
why am i going um
i'm going because it's a once in
a lifetime
experience like
i just literally don't think i'll ever
have the chance to do it again
um so while i'm young i just want to go
okay
what can i drive stick no i wish i could
um
much love from notre dame thank you um
who's sad am i on abba or fresh um
[Music]
maybe abba probably abba um
what happened to my face oh
i'm dumb i can't i picked out a a zit
and i made it like
i i irritated the skin so i just put
that on
the
leg
i don't know i don't want to scar
um
you live am i scared of getting taken in
europe um
not necessarily not really
um
i mean it could happen but i'm not
overly worried
am i backpacking
um probably not backpacking probably
like a suitcase i don't know um the last
half of the trip isn't for a year so i'm
gonna be living in an apartment in
downtown london and then after that i'll
like figure it out
oh my gosh people driving on the wrong
side of the road i forget about that
well i only said maybe abba because
i kind of forgot but
like you don't insult a guy's wife so
oh my goodness
does it just freeze when i cut out i
don't actually know
but i'm excited when i get to europe
guys my content is going to be so much
more consistent on a schedule because
gosh i have been traveling like
for the last like three weeks and i am
so tired i'm so excited to go home
i am going to a pickup like event like
where they teach guys how to get girls
tonight and i'm going to be like
documenting all of it so this is like my
last
big piece of content while i'm here
um
so i don't have a dog
it's like purely for entertainment
purposes and just to like give you guys
the information if
um
you know if it's good or not but
yeah um reach out to better bachelor i
probably will when i get to europe i'm
gonna be so much more consistent
um in my uploading schedule um what
country do you eventually want to settle
in um i want to settle in the us um i
just like want to go to europe for now
what differences do you see in european
women versus
american women um so it's interesting
because like a lot of the manosphere
will say that like european women are
more traditional and i think that's
maybe true in like eastern european
countries
um but i lived in germany for three
months and like to be honest
the girls there were definitely not more
traditional
well
i'm trying to think
like when i think like the girls there
were a lot more like sexually active
like that's what i remember is i
remember being like
18 and i was a virgin and i just
remember like all the girls there were
like so shocked that i was that old and
still a virgin like
um
so that's what i remember i'm i i guess
they're probably a little bit more
motherly like i was raised by european
nannies so i think it's pretty typical
for european like girls to go be nannies
for a year or german girls to go be
nannies for a year but
yeah like that was my
experience are you excited to taste the
food in europe i'm excited for kabobs in
germany i know i'm gonna go to germany
sometime in this year and what i do i'm
getting kebabs
um would i debate my run if he accepted
um
i wouldn't go back on their podcast
because like i think i'm sure you guys
saw the video like i just didn't like
the way
and it's funny because people are like
why are you traitor you you hate on
freshman but i didn't like say anything
wrong i just said i wouldn't go back on
a podcast with two guys that i barely
know like if
if
almost complete stranger screamed at you
after a podcast or like yelled at you
you probably wouldn't want to go back on
so i don't think that's like a super big
deal to be honest
um
like i i literally don't think that's a
big deal
um
but if he maybe on like a third party
platform but i wouldn't go back on his
um
i swear i witnessed menu nating in the
middle of the street in london
oh gosh um okay
i'm gonna pick up girls tonight no i'm
gonna watch people pick up girls i'm
gonna watch people i will not be picking
up girls well
i mean i don't know if they would need
me to help with something i probably
would i'm kind of nervous about the
footage because i don't know the best
way to film in clubs
but i guess i'm gonna learn on the go
um you need advice my neighbors are
vegan and they talk about veganism how
do i make them stop
um
you don't
um
i don't know p like maybe find different
friends
um
i'm filming in field
yes
um i am i don't know how i'm gonna do my
best to
am i attracted to black guys i mean my
boyfriend's black so yes um
the man of sphere knows nothing outside
the u.s
and european women are not anything
traditional but they are walking and
shouting alpha females like clowns in
the states i mean that was my impression
like it was funny because you always
hear about how girls from other
countries and maybe that's true with
like latina girls or like girls from
down south are more traditional but when
i was in europe like if anything like
the girls were more like i meant more
liberal girls more feminists um
more girls that like were sexually
active at a younger age
um like bigger partiers if anything
um
yes that was my experience but i'm i'm
not saying like
that's the ultimate truth i was just in
germany so i was in one country in
europe for a long period of time
um talk to them constantly about
delicious steak and chicken and if they
say something
say how do you like that what
but i actually grew up with european
nannies so i guess they were like they
were girls typically and they were a
little bit more traditional because
um
like obviously they were doing the
cooking cleaning in our house because
they're nannies but
and like taking care of the kids
so
am i gonna play a professional
basketball in london um no i'm playing
semi-pro basketball so
um because i went to
a division three school it's a lot
harder to be recruited to a pro team
overseas um and i think i probably could
sorry guys i'm
i like do not
know why this keeps cutting out okay but
a way to
go pro is to go to a school in london
and play for a semi-pro team for a year
and that way you're going to be
recruited to coaches that are overseas
um
so i don't know if i'll want to go pro
the year after like i don't know if
it'll be one year or two um
right now i'm just going to see how year
one goes yep see what happens but
yeah that's like my plan right now
do you think in western europe there are
still less school diggers in the us um
because of stronger welfare if it's it's
still the same
um
i don't know why my gut is telling me
more
but i don't really have a good reason
for that like that's just my gut feeling
not researched at all um
i heard women in germany although
they're feminists they're more
traditional that might be true that
might be true
um they're definitely like
sexually active younger age from my
experience and they're definitely more
liberal like typically
what sports do i play i play basketball
and volleyball
let's see if there's any
let me see if there's any comments that
i have
um
oh my gosh
okay sorry guys
it's the hotel
it is the hotel wi-fi okay um do i think
i'm marriageable and if so why um i
would say like as a girl i have like
strengths and weaknesses so
um to be honest i would say yes only
because i think women today are like
less marriageable than ever so i think
it's pretty easy to like
be a girl that's marriageable if i'm
being honest like i think it's
easier than ever before
i mean oh do you know there's challenges
because men are less willing to like
commit but i think guys that like do
want a wife and do want to get married
like
it's easier to like become marriageable
because like honestly the
the bar isn't that high like there are
guys saying like only five to ten
percent of girls are marriageable
um
i don't think it's crazy like that crazy
hard to be in that percent um but i
definitely have like strengths and
weaknesses as a girl i would say like
a strength of mine as i'm very agreeable
and very helpful so
and i'm like really willing to learn so
i'm
just in general like
i'm a very good i've never been like the
type to
take charge of a room and just like
order people around like i've always
always always my whole life
loved being like a second in command
like second in command to someone so if
i do have someone that's like very
direct on what they want
um i like usually listen like
um
so i would say that probably works in my
favor i will say like i'm not a really
girly and that probably doesn't like
um
like i don't i don't i'm not really like
super into makeup and like hair and like
i'm pretty like laid back with that
stuff so i'd say that probably doesn't
work in my favor
um
i'm also like not
the neatest um to be honest like i do
okay but
like if you want like that super
traditional like cooking and cleaning
life like i just would prefer
to make enough money to hire someone to
do that like that's just how i'd rather
do it maybe i could cook but like i'd
really like to have cleaners my parents
had cleaners
growing up and it just made a lot of
stuff like easier
and i don't really see why
like people are so fixated on having
like the wife clean when you can just
hire someone to do that
um and it's really not even that
expensive these days to have someone
come like once or twice a week
so
like do i think i'm marriageable
yeah i think there are definitely guys
out there that would marry me um
but at the same time like i'm not
perfect and they're like things i could
definitely work on to be like a better
person and a like a better wife someday
let me make sure that the ubereats is
here
um
oh gosh okay
um okay uber eats when is it coming
okay i got
um okay well in the uk are you planning
on traveling to countryside
you know it's an unended live when the
host checks their delivery order
i know guys i promise when i get to
london like shit's gonna be so much more
professional and edited but i have just
been like traveling from place to place
and like my life has been so like
inconsistent lately it has just been so
hard to like keep to a normal schedule
um but i swear i swear when i get to
england it's going to be so much more
consistent
um i'm just like i've been so
people have been like commenting that my
face is like super broken out and i know
it is but it's because i've been so
stressed out trying to get everything
ready to literally move to another
country
like i'm behind on stuff okay
um okay when you're in the uk are you
planning on traveling to the countryside
portions of england for the getaway
weekends are there any particular
landmarks and um that you want to see
while you're there i
i i
i don't even know what i want to see i
know i want to go to ireland and if
there's any like redhead fest i want to
go i 100 want to go
um i'm a big history person i'd like to
see
[Music]
um some castles for sure
um
what else do i want to do i want to do
everything like i want to go to germany
i want to go
to the netherlands i want to go to italy
again um there's so much i want to do
if you get married are you going to
accept your man to exercise his options
okay
i think people really confuse
my views on this i'm really looking for
someone with the same values as me so
um when i get married
no like i would not be cool with him
exercising his options
um
like because you have to think about it
this way like at the end of the day
people have desires to do things i have
no doubt that like men have the desire
to cheat i think women have the desire
to cheat too like i think people in
general like have the desire to do bad
things but it all comes down to like
self-control
and like your values and your like
morals
so
no like i would not be cool with that
um
i do i will say i do understand girls
staying like once there are kids because
like once there are kids like it's not
about you anymore so that's completely
different but like before kids no
um okay
if you're going to do a meet and greet i
live in the uk i probably will at some
point
i don't know what the ban on d
is
okay don't forget to visit chicken shops
if you have a boyfriend isn't that going
to put a bit of strain on it moving away
to europe
i'm sure it's not gonna be easy to be
honest like
but like luckily i have to come back for
a wedding in like a month and then like
maybe he'll visit me once and then you
know thanksgiving so i don't know
there'll be times when i go
um
can we stop acting like all men exercise
their options
that's what i'm saying i don't i have no
idea what the percentage of men is but
when i was talking to myron on the show
what i was saying is i asked him do you
think all men cheat when given the
option and he said yes
um
and that's just not like what i have
seen
uh it never works my parents actually
did long distance for two years
um i think it works if there's an end
date i don't think it works over college
typically because that's like
indefinitely but i think
if you have the means like if you have
the money to visit each other and it's
for a specific period of time and you
know like coming back what's next
um i do think it works
but i mean i'm sure the odds aren't in
your favor
um how was the visa process so i should
get my visa back in five days but the
process
is literally like so frustrating like so
frustrating
okay
um
are there any restrictions entering the
uk um you have to quarantine if you're
not vaccinated but i'll be vaccinated
before i go
i think they're trying to change the
culture if uber is five minutes away
um
okay let's see i think they're trying to
change the culture and convince men that
it's okay to cheat
i think people project so if you can't
control yourself you just assume that
like other people are like that too and
i don't even
disagree that maybe like over 50 of men
are like that but
there are good guys that aren't like
that and i'm never gonna like discount
that
you know there are guys that know how to
control themselves and like not put
themselves in situations where they'll
be tempted and that's the thing like
people will be like oh like if they had
only fans models like after them every
single day you don't think they'd say
yes i'm like well you don't put yourself
in situations that
you know that would happen
uber eats
what oh my gosh this smoothie i ordered
a smoothie and it's literally going to
be melted by the time it comes
um
have i seen king richard's channel no i
have not
um actually recorded it
um
do you think a man who is not monogamous
will have a tough time finding anything
long-term with a woman um no i really
don't i think there's a lot of girls
like that are willing to accept that so
i don't have a problem with
people wanting to do that
i just wouldn't sign up for it that's
not like my values it's not my belief
systems system
but there's definitely guys that will
have i thought about how the changing
climate might affect my health
is it that different isn't it just like
i didn't i don't even know no i haven't
looked at that at all
um
cold and rainy yeah i mean
it gets cold and rainy here it's not
really a problem so no i'm not too
worried
why this is taking forever i'm so hungry
um
yeah i don't know i just have always
wanted to live in europe for like a long
period of time and that's why
i'm excited
i might have a problem with the water
and local germs oh gosh well i can use a
brita i'd imagine i'm pretty good at
like figuring out problems to be honest
like i'm actually pretty good at that
um
best time i ever had hanging out met a
lot of travelers from ireland and
scotland
that's the plan oh my gosh i'm so
excited i'm going to literally see the
world and it's going to be so freaking
cool like so cool
um okay if you guys don't have any more
questions i think i'm going to log off
of here i just wanted to give like a you
know
quick live
um does anyone have any more questions
i'll give you guys like 30 seconds
okay
um okay guys well thanks for coming on
um i promise when i get to london this
shit's gonna be so much more consistent
i'm just i'm so tired guys i cannot wait
to like be in one place
and
um do i like traveling youtubers i love
traveling youtubers and i guess i'm
gonna be one soon
um
in 10 years um i see myself married and
maybe
24 34 maybe like pregnant with a kid